goats chickens and geese all live
together in this farm it might look a
bit chaotic but it all makes sense the
baton of the pigeons wings functions as
ventilation cooling the air as a
consequence the rabbits have more babies
than the wood if it were hotter
veterinarian Michael ba ba GA explains
this another innovation that is murder
from the Maison de panne sauna in Venice
so the many farmers will come to visit
the budget a is well known across West
Africa for his radical ideas we have 16
species of livestock here the idea is to
create synergies that had value villages
can adopt our methods because they are
based on traditional husbandry we have
just optimized this we show farmers how
these methods and help them make I think
I will be able to look after my animals
better with his methods and have a
better life for myself
the average weight of dr. BIR budget is
adult pigs is 150 kilos that is a lot
for Africa because the souls are well
fed they have between eight and twelve
piglets and one liter he feeds his pigs
with remnants from other animals
slaughtered on his farm it is an easy
form of recycling and it does not cost a
lot quite a long time
dr. Baba Judah was something of an
outsider and been a agronomist was
subscribed to european-style mass
industrial farming rejected his ideas
and excluded him from academic circles
it was imaginative for years and years
the professors taught that you must not
give different kinds of animals together
and now they have improved Rami I had
lots of problems with the university and
the minister for 17 years but I stood up
today I was kept out of all seminars and
workshops but that has not rained at
benna's largest university though the
agricultural science textbooks which are
from frost date from the 1970s
Benny has been independent for six
decades but the influence of his former
colonial ruler is still much in evidence
[Music]
the university does not have many
computers and Internet access is not
widespread
Luke dosa is a professor of Agriculture
his studied and taught in Germany and
has studied the different traditions of
animal husbandry in Europe and Africa
he says the African model has a lot
going for it all test books teach
industrial livestock production with
each specially held separately but
traditional methods are making a
comeback also in Europe many people are
very critical of factory farming
nowadays we are not interested in
intensive farming but in extensive
farming
Stasi dr. Baba ji sees this shift as an
endorsement of his approach which has
always conceded the right one more and
more student of agronomy come to see him
and his farm
no key focus he finished University when
they graduate and come yet I have to
reprogram and reformat them so they
think like farmers the past calmly
family international aid organizations
are showing an interest in his methods
the UN's Food and Agriculture
Organization has expressed interest in
his work
dr. Baba ji day is about to go on a
lecture tour to Congo Gabon Cameroon and
EJ the outsider has finally become a
role model